stop the show Gang we got a little tour
update coming at you to stay trashy tour
is rolling along Vermont and Connecticut
we added second shows we'll be there
this weekend baby get the squad and come
out and see us yeah gang then we're
going to be uh in Tampa Florida second
show out of there get those tickets
limited tickets left then we're going to
Dania Beach Florida Raleigh North
Carolina Louisville Kentucky Cleveland
Ohio then Columbus Ohio get those
tickets it's a good time a little ayg
with the crowd some stand-up comedy
we'll see you there more dates coming
welcome so another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that at
the group to be classy after just a big
old piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at Toadies in the
new edition baby oh she's out there
spending that money thinking about
putting in a pool table for the summer
oh God see how it works out my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman and the word
on Wall Street is you think about
scooping up a couple of these banks that
are pinned up about to find themselves
between a rock and a forehead give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey what's up
Ken got me got me at the buzzer meter
right there what's up everybody thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate if you subscribe on iTunes full
video of album on YouTube as you know
those numbers are cooking and obviously
I don't have to say it in this room the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com check it the [__] out
gang it's a already over to air yes sir
and having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
works the twos works the threes and the
fours now crosses the t's and dots the
eyes and now you can get a little peek
at him on the Toby cam ladies but no
touchy touchy give it up for T-Bone
McGruff and stubby McMullen everybody
what up dudes there he is Yo gas up the
jet grab the caviar we got the big homie
oh yeah the long hair ain't lying it
might be warm outside but we got the
heat on in here baby I'll tell you that
right now we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guests back with us
again today this man has led more people
to the promised land than Moses himself
he is the international Sensation that
has swept the nation he is the light
that shows us the way give it up for the
King of New York Andrew Schultz
everybody let's go
bro first of all I told you guys this a
million times when I walked in but the
new studio is absolutely unbelievable
I've done like a whole tour not yet
rooms and everything yeah not yet we're
going to I've walked in and the waiting
room could be a set sure yeah yeah it's
unbelievable we went we went big toe
stood he's spending the [__] cut man
yeah yeah yeah
and also the intro was was Immaculate
thank you buddy do you guys remember
that show where they uh it was like a
Japanese game show where they dubbed
over Maximum extreme maximum extreme
Challenge mxc they need to get you guys
yeah oh that would be a good time well
Japanese television money I'm about it
let's go let's go you talk to someone
Schultz get me locked in I'm gonna make
it this guy plus I hear the milk in
Japan is really really good you have
great milk
they almost had a bag of the day mtv2
bought the rights to that and then they
um had Damien lemon and I okay no [__]
yeah that's all right yeah didn't make
it but I I think you guys could pull it
off 100 but I wouldn't even have you
guys dubbed I think I would have you
guys actually just making fun of
Japanese people slipping that's what
happened that's what I call Chrissy D
jammed up yeah yeah yeah yeah that is
true not for Netflix
uh buddy I gotta ask you uh the cut the
haircut yes yeah we were talking about
that before doing a little shooting I
was doing a movie hold on this is how
cool you are I didn't even think
anything of it I was just like this is
[__] this is
yeah yeah I'm also slightly offended by
that you should be here you should be I
meant it as a little bit of an it was a
dig for sure I'm such a [__]
sociopath I would walk around like this
thinking people would be normal I could
tell and I'm always very jealous of that
yeah that you know to be to have the
haircut for whatever you're working on
yeah I've done that in my lowest points
I've gotten a regular haircut and been
like yeah I'm shooting something next
week I gotta get my haircut for it but
usually just the the production company
does that yeah no you were trying to get
laid I remember the story he told a girl
he was on Boardwalk Empire one night and
then was gonna see her the next day and
went and got his hair cut like Boardwalk
didn't work
that was supposed to be again they
showed up the next day looking like
Buscemi I was like what the [__] is this
smoking on filters and drinking whiskey
in the morning I love it yeah yeah no I
was doing this uh what do you got
cooking up in uh we were shooting up in
Calgary but it's uh it's called the
thicket and it's uh it's got a Peter
Dinklage in it I don't know I love
Dinklage oh he's a man dude yeah so I
was like hell yeah I'll do that [__] I
want to make I want to make a couple
movies so I'm learning how to behave and
it's appearance it's a period piece it's
like 1908. yeah sharp Duds I don't know
what that means sharp wardrobe oh
actually I'll show you I'll show you
guys a picture yeah I'm like a pimp in
1908.
yeah it's fire so it was fun fun cool
little project and you're done with it
now yeah yeah we're finished so if they
tell you to keep the cup for a little
while no if they want to do reshoots bro
no but uh that's funny that you say that
sometimes they do do that but uh I just
got made fun of so much by my boys for
having it that I think I have to keep it
yeah you just just lean into it I just
think I have to you already took the
heat exactly yeah now you look cool and
if I change it because they clown me
then I'm just a [__] you've lost yeah
yeah then they know they can just [__]
on you and you're gonna have to change
next time too exactly so I gotta yeah
yeah you gotta digital [__] lessons
and I'll tell you what I guarantee you
see a couple of those cuts starting to
pop up because they saw schultzie
this summer cool guy shot you come in
tomorrow I got it
I got the receding hairline with the
cool sides
you're in one of those worlds where like
cool as walk is wonky so it's like you
can do anything and you still come off
as cool you know I don't know because
you have confidence to do it am I cool I
don't know about that do we want to be
the coolest guy what do you mean I mean
I don't think you're trying to be cool I
think you're very genuinely authentic
your person you're not trying to be cool
yeah just you're just cool you're just a
cool dude I'll take it okay
Chelsea I love you Jesus
you guys got to do the tour of the
studio it's unbelievable yeah we will be
a patreon www.patreon.com all right sign
up sign up to the page check it out gang
yeah yeah yeah it's just great love what
you guys have done thank you buddy
following in your footsteps man thank
you for laying the ground pave in your
own way and yeah it's it's cool to see
um cool to see your guys in influence
[Music]
I think the sign of success is that like
okay cool haircuts that's what he means
no like cool haircuts you pave away and
then I think other people I think as
human beings we look at things that are
successful and we go okay wow there is
an opportunity here you know and I think
that that's you know I think that's how
a judge a sign of success a lot of
people have been putting on weight guys
[Laughter]
all I'm trying to say is this is Growing
Pains this is awesome this is awesome
thank you man thank you very much I've
always said I always thank you we've
taken a page out of your book and uh you
know eventually I appreciate the
guidance you've always been there
whenever I call I text whatever the only
question I have of course are awesome
but listen those are [__] amazing and
uh you guys you have a great product I
remember the first time watching I think
I thought it was on the first time here
and I was like holy [__] like this is it
I think I hit I don't know I think I hit
you and I originally I was like make it
shorter make it 15 minutes and I was
like and I like what you guys have
obviously done you guys he'll never let
me live in a 20-minute version because
in my mind the only only thing that I
had seen that was anything like in the
world was the the eat chicken that's hot
yeah yeah and it's like
this is so much better because you don't
have to eat chicken do you know what I
mean like like it's just you get all the
wings
I'm like what are you talking about one
thing he hates about the show wait can
we open the biscuits what the [__] is
going on over here
sitting here without wings that's how we
doing mozzarella sticks get a sampler
but yeah I was just like this is it what
a great way to go on there be vulnerable
and like brag about how trash you are
and everybody wants to share the stories
like you just created this great great
vehicle it's one of those shows where
where I think about people I want to be
on that then we get that a lot sure like
bird will hit us up he's like you gotta
have you got it yeah I was looking at
[__] daily the picture right there
Guy Fieri there it is yeah there's so
many so many awesome but that's how you
know you have a product like people do
that with Rogan right like you you see
some you know scientist or a guy who's
like an egyptologist or a great new
comedian you're like yo you need to go
on Rogan right and it's because we feel
like something special would happen sure
so yeah yeah yeah now you got me cooking
I got to think about people I really
want to see
you got to get the Chicken Guy you got
to get hot chicken guy we we we were I
think somebody connected us at some
point yeah yeah oh really
[Laughter]
the less successful Dahmer
can't get his act together I'm out of
gas
oh man that's funny to that end of who
people you want on the podcast we
haven't had you on in a little while I
know we want to do a little recap you
know what I mean we got a couple of new
cues here we want we want to toss at you
see what's going on let's do it
um just off off the rip doing well
deserve everything you got let's not
forget that thanks you saw the uh the 52
Grand back there yeah for Mr Segura from
his birthday dinner wow do you got
anything that can compare to that what
are you dropping these days on a nice
Dentin the most I've spent on a dinner
you take 15 people
it's a lot it's a lot it's a lot yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and I do feel guilty if they pay is that
weird you shoot are they they're all
your employees if it's us yeah you
should yeah yeah they were I mean if
you're going out with other Rich guys
you know you can spread the wealth oh no
no we definitely yeah if you're the
richest guy at the table you got to put
it down you gotta do it yeah yeah
otherwise I'd be dude if we went out and
you were like Kevin you let Toby pay
never never once never once Toby nah
dude good he doesn't even fake reach for
him
and wouldn't kill him to pick up an Uber
from time to time well I'm gonna I'm
gonna split his taxes right off what are
we talking about that's right I love
when people act like tax write-ups make
it free yeah I kind of tell you know
nobody's written off what do you mean
you're gonna write it off
pay the [__] [__] taxes
in our head that's all free yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna learn the hard way
we're downsizing the studio
that's how I knew that club was going
under because they they started with
Voss and like three weeks later they
were on Poland Spring and I was like oh
this [__] is closing dude soak up the
spots while you can but Poland Spring in
three weeks that's a tough that's a you
know it's glass bottles to the [__] that
don't even stand on the table
you know someone got that for that that
monthly invoice and was like what the
you spending three grand on Water I got
it we're about to turn the lights off in
here oh man yeah I'm trying to think
most expensive because you go out a lot
you know you go out a lot yeah it's
nothing like time I mean 52 is great
well now that we just did ymh as well
and he said we we talked about it and he
was like that was a shut the restaurant
down and fill it with like friends that
was like uh that was a big big to-do
most expensive so far I haven't gotten
paid back for this I don't know if I'll
get paid back from who but uh uh burning
man taking the boys to burning oh that
looked oh that was that was all fresh
Duds and everything too yeah yeah that
was uh that was probably expensive and
I'm supposed to get paid back but it's
like so much time has gone yeah you
can't what was the deal I'll get it and
then everybody send me X and nobody sent
X yeah I think I don't know they all
took it
yeah as long as we're making money I
don't even know I was there man in the
same way yeah yeah like I will figure
that out at the end of the month but if
like if one month anything dips like
you're gonna be hitting everybody else
yeah yeah yeah yeah I finally got the
AmEx card I mean like who the [__] is
Toby just for an example where'd you hit
this week where have you had dinner this
week are you have eaten dinner at home
you know we do I think uh no this week
is early so nothing really so far but uh
because the missus doesn't right at the
house oh she does but she's like to go
out too she likes to go out
Penny on uh on going out to dinner but
that's how we I know that's we that's
how we party if you will like we're not
sure
and then just judge
the greatest people in the world at
their craft yeah that's one amazing
thing when you go out to a restaurant
and the nicer the restaurant like for
example like a restaurant that doesn't
have a Michelin star and a restaurant
that does the amount of like judgment
attention to a Michelin because you're
like do you deserve it you act like you
[__] am I you're up eating at dinos you
know what I mean like you're giving them
the star like you're the guy who decides
if they get another star you're just
gonna get off the wall I was eating
chicken fingers on the way there in the
Uber I don't [__] know anything
I literally my whole life was was diners
which are the best places they're dying
in New York now though they [__] are
they really there's like these guys
doesn't even know diners are gone
guys life is good
[Music]
you guys
if things are going well yeah I'll have
an omelette it's crazy about the price
of eggs
dude I didn't notice that at all bro I
saw all these people crying about the
price of eggs I'm like what the [__] is
happening a dollar more you have quails
Drop Eggs off on your balcony every
morning
[Laughter]
how bad did eggs get I don't I mean we
live in New York so it's like oh it went
from you know nine dollars to I don't
know I think in Middle America where
they were like 99 Cents like a dozen
yeah I think it went up to like five six
seven eight bucks or something yeah but
New York it's like living in a [__]
airport man everything's expensive yeah
but I don't know I feel like we freak
out a lot about that I mean this is
gonna sound so [__] pretentious but
like people do free they'll be like gas
went from 350 to four what is that five
dollars
I think that was always my thought too
but I think that affects the price of
every good then because you got to
transport it Transportation James
everybody up flights go up yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah then we should complain
about that yeah well yeah I guess
because when the pump goes up 50 cents
it's like yeah I think we can manage
sure sure if it was just that but when
it does we're you know like jamming
everybody up yeah but I feel like we
take it out like I see the price go up
and then people go [__] Ukraine yeah
oh
I don't know how anything connects yeah
that's that's like the smartest thing I
ever said I don't know one after it you
don't need to know anything I'm also big
on having something to complain about so
if I can if I can throw it on you know
Ukraine some anything gas prices
something somebody's getting it
everybody's just trying to connect dots
like milk goes up goddamn Justin Bieber
I know yeah just [__] [__] just
kidding I will I will say that's
something that I learned from like
making money is that like you care so
much less about [__] and then the people
who are way more wealthy that care
you're like man you don't really care
about that yeah it's all a game like no
you mean lightly you mean like the stuff
where people come out like a famous
person will come out and be like you
think that Leonardo DiCaprio gives a
[__] about trees
there's no way he's in Saint Bart you
gotta take five flights to get the
[__] same Parts okay there's no way
he can you just need a cause that isn't
gonna piss off Republicans Or democrats
yeah you need like a uh you need one in
the middle and so they all still buy
tickets to the movies
is like
I don't know that's there is some beauty
in knowing that like these people don't
really care but they kind of gotta care
sure like that's the genius of like a
like a Warren Buffett like because if
you got tons of money and you act like
it people hate hate you they [__]
despise you might drive the same car
live in the same house every day Warren
Buffett takes a picture once a year on a
bench drinking a diet coke with khakis
and we believe that's his [__] life
then he puts on a solid gold suit
exactly I leave the video after when he
like throws the diet coke steps in a
Rolls-Royce smacks a girl in the [__]
face gets blown by some 14 year old boy
and does what billionaires do sure that
makes sense I never thought about it
there's no way he lives in the same
house in where is it Omaha Omaha
Nebraska yeah Omaha Nebraska Omaha
Nebraska I've been to Omaha Nebraska he
doesn't live in Omaha Nebraska they find
some old guy from the [__] Six Flags
commercials
Warren Buffett there's no way but it's
genius because nobody shits on Warren
Buffett some guy in a body suit cutting
the grass exactly I love them but we
love him because he acts like he's poor
you need to damn and if you don't that
this is what the billionaires do and you
have to because we'll just kill him if
you don't if you have tons of money and
you want to like spend it and have fun
you need to buy a newspaper to defend
you all the time so that damn we got to
get a newspaper
I don't know if we're there talking a
paper route either I want to own the
thing but that's what like Bill Gates
has you know MSNBC like Ms is Microsoft
NBC and uh is it yeah we don't even know
we just see that [__] lesbian yapping
on the TV all the time we're like ah
there's nothing to do with Bill Gates
but there's uh it is yeah Bezos says
watching the post
they all have a newspaper
shout out to him he's out there yeah
nice piece on his side I feel he's all
[__] rare yeah bro he did the wildest
Rich [__] ever they broke down uh he
made a boat in like the Netherlands or
some [__] they're good at making boats
over there and a super yacht and the
yacht was so big it couldn't pass
through this
um little like River area because there
was a bridge that was built in like the
1500s so we had we had them just take
down the bridge yeah it's wild and then
put the bridge back up yeah when you can
change roads and stuff that's [__]
house roads is one thing a bridge Old
Bridge from the 1500s bro probably some
paperwork involved for that a little bit
Yeah Yeah shout out to them you started
that [__] in this [__] garage bro
he's flexing on the soup so that's the
other thing okay let's talk about that
Helix Helix Helix Helix I can't stress
it enough gang Helix Helix is the best
let me tell you something getting older
ain't great that things start getting
getting sore stiff I noticed that in the
bed that I have now like my knees start
hurting just from laying there over at
Helix man that's all they're focused on
is getting you the best night's sleep
that's absolutely possible legally yeah
all right I sleep in a helix all the
time I'm limber you see my high kicks
recently over there and a few things are
pretty good that's I attribute all that
to Helix baby uh Helix mattresses are
here to improve your sleep cushioning
those joints and muscles and giving you
more energy for each day I've been
saying for years it's the best sleep
I've ever had it's adult sleep it's a
grown-up bed you get it together get
your life together in a helix but you
gotta take the quiz and what's that it's
like you got to study four and four or
five times
you take the Sleep quiz they match up
with the best thing you don't got to go
to the Community College on a Saturday
and take it around like that you go
right online throw it on your phone
uh you take advantage of their 100 night
free trial and a 10 to 15 year
warranties choose from 14 unique
mattresses including luxury models big
and tall for the big man and mattresses
just for kids every Helix mattress comes
with steel coils in the base foam layers
on top for a combination of comfort and
support getting better sleep couldn't be
easier your personalized mattress to
ship to your door for free and delivered
in a box for easy setup here is the
turkey go to heal it on me uh Helix is
offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to yieldsleep.com garbage
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now do it do it Kim this is
Bluetooth yeah no I mean why I have a
raging hard on right now something you
can swing for it's Bluetooth yeah is
what I got going on down here uh stop
looking at me like that by the way
okay do yourself a favor get over to
Bluetooth get yourself straightened out
bluetooth deliver chewable tablets with
the same active ingredients as Viagra
Cialis Levitra at a fraction of the cost
I don't even hurdle Levitra yeah I
thought that was margarine get Bluetooth
yeah instead guys that was please no
that's it you find out when you take it
it ain't messing around this is the real
deal Holyfield stuff you know what I
mean
[Laughter]
about to take a run at you me and you
could take some and have some sword
fights in here sign up for bluetooth.com
meet with one of their licensed medical
providers and receive your prescription
in days the best part it's all online no
doctor's visits or awkward conversation
with the doctors nosy secretaries asking
you questions Sarah why are your bands
off in the waiting room Bluetooth habits
are made in the USA and shipped to your
door in discreet packaging Bluetooth
wants to help you have better sex
discover your options at bluetooth.com
chew it and do it special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code garbage at checkout
just paying five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code garbage to receive your first
free month visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast
we love you
but I will say this I was talking to
Rogan I was like I was like shout out
Joe Rogan yo shut up I want to hear you
because you guys are out there like a
[__] Legend but I was like yo does
anybody kick because I find myself just
caring about less things like I care
about my boys I care about my family
like I you know it's just a smaller I
care about you know I care about you
guys I love seeing you guys succeed and
I like seeing other you know my boys
being but like caring about who the
[__] governor of some state is I
don't give a [__] about whatever
Direction I don't care I think my thing
is I never cared for the longest time my
main care was paying rent my cell phone
getting cut off all that kind of [__] so
it was like I mean up until you know
[__] 18 months ago or whatever it was
two years I was like that was my main
call like my main thing and now I'm like
I don't give a [__] about I just don't I
also don't have an opinion on anything
political no I don't know I'm just an
interesting I used to know I didn't even
know [__] Ms stood for Microsoft yeah
Chelsea's going to Mars
I might take a trip bro
Bezos hits me up he drives me I take a
little trip I go to bars it's just the
wildest thing man like to fake like I
have I have my friends that like still
are like politically engaged and [__]
and they'll be like these drag queens
are teaching kids or whatever like have
you heard this thing it's like the new
thing and I'll have to be like
I do not care if the drag queens are
teaching my kids you don't have any skin
in the game at the moment exactly you
have no skin in the game but that's what
Rogan said he's like yo once you have
kids you start caring about everything
again it's not about you it's just about
the kids yeah of course in the world
that they could grow up and I was like
okay that makes sense so now I'm in this
like weird time where my wife and I are
[__] trying to have kids but we don't
have them yet so I'm just enjoying being
able to not not care about anything
about anything you're over there judging
spicy tuna rolls
given the sous chef dirty looks it was
wet why is this tuner wall so wet buddy
where'd you get this uni the East River
are you reading anything right now ah
dude I read books I read uh uh I'm
trying to like learn how to
trying to learn how to to write a a
movie I want to okay so I'm learning I'm
reading all these books about story and
by reading I mean I'm just listening to
the [__] sure of course and in 2023
what are we doing here but you don't
keep it in as much no you don't retain
it at all it's like it's just like it's
like music in the car in the background
you don't retain it you have to listen
to it three times yeah so I don't know
if I'm saving time doing this listening
[__] it's true yeah you're not really
yeah you retain it way different yeah so
I'm into uh reading so I read this book
about William store wrote it and then a
new one I'm wearing a hero with a
thousand faces I think it's like a
Joseph is it Joseph Campbell or
something like that so I'm just trying
to like read about like stories and when
do you listen to these on the treadmill
before I go to bed before you go to bed
but if you're listening around yeah yeah
yeah but then I'll throw the earpods on
you have the earpods on in bed yeah
sometimes really yeah yeah yeah yeah you
do the pods or you do like the big bows
no no I'll do the pods you guys so wifey
doesn't really wake up she's good at
like she sleeps with like Harry Potter
on every night so she's fine going to
sleep you guys going to sleep with the
TV on she does and I turn it off
immediately after she falls asleep okay
all right that's pretty cool she she
likes that that's comfort for her that's
good the Harry pots pretty good not bad
um got a king-sized bed I assume
California King Mommy
now why is that why is that important
what because it's bigger but it's not no
it is no it's it's long it's longer not
as wide yeah yeah it's not as wide as a
king I think it's the same let me get
some Dimension but there's another
there's one big there's an Alaska that's
the biggest I there's a bigger one I'm
like [__] really uh-huh yeah hey and a
twin that's all you got to work have you
guys been to Alaska no if you go to
Alaska you'll find out why it's the
biggest bet
this is what it's huge no there's some
big broads you're gonna need some square
footage in a bed like that there's some
big girls it's like five to one men to
women men to women so there's no like
incentive for women to be in shape
there's nothing it's like there's guys
are starving their crab fishing they're
coming off the boat and they're like
I'll [__] anything sure so these girls
are just walking around blowing
cigarettes they don't give a flying [__]
wearing the hoodies with the mustard
stains like they do not have hair sounds
like fun
literally you're an eight out there as a
woman hello boys here out by the docks
I got some crabs here for you all right
California King dimensions 84 inches
long 72 inches wide regular King side
king size 80 inches long 76 inches wide
so it's two inches wider uh four inches
wider the regular King is wider and then
the California king is longer correct
yeah
not bad yeah yeah okay so why don't you
just go regular King
because you'll fit I mean it's not like
you're you're not [__] checked I'll
say this you want to save a little room
in in a New York City bedrooms plus if
people come over to look at the
apartment and they go into the bedroom
California King really Rose does it yeah
it sounds better because it's not King
it's a local California it's an upgrade
yeah interesting yeah yeah yeah well you
or the wife when you leave a place like
if you leave like a hotel room or like
say you guys stare at like yep right now
yeah of course you guys leave at the
like on the dresser before you leave uh
depends uh I typically have merch cash
so I like I have cash I'll probably a
night 10 to 20.
per night per night yeah we're only
we're doing one nighter like we're in
and we're out for the most part we're
not doing like weekends anywhere I'm a
big Tipper uh-huh I almost never tip the
cleaning crew you gotta change that I
know because I reached there found out
they're paid per room not hour
they're paid per unit
and it's like a shitty rate I found out
can't drop a twenty you gotta grease
I found out I mean I assumed that they
were making six figs all these years
these poor Latvian women walking around
the hotels knocking on all that money
you guys
are salaried right you got full bennies
us just going later and she's like I
need this money yes I get 75 cents per
rule something like that yeah but what
about all your stock options yeah you
got you got a tip heavy yeah okay yeah I
gotta create that but what I was gonna
say is if you guys like rent a house or
something like that yeah do you ever say
goodbye to places like or like you know
if you're leaving somewhere like thank
you house no never no all right yeah but
I don't mind that uh as a sentiment I
like that because that means the
placements on me to you but no no sure I
would actually I would really love to
find a place that
um
you know like when you're a kid I don't
know if you guys did as a kid but like
you're you your family found a place the
parents enjoyed it the kids enjoyed it
and they just went back there sure oh of
course and they just got so much joy out
of this house that's the Harbor House in
Ocean City for the Foley family boom you
used to go there every summer get to the
water yeah enjoy it the parents get to
kind of let you off the leash a little
bit they get to kick back and I hope
that my wife and I find a place like
that well you're trying I see the
[__] Instagram stories you're [__]
trying but I don't know I have this
weird thing now where it's like
I kind of want to see everything which I
don't know if that's the best way to go
through life because if you're just
skimming the top you might you're not
really getting like hey we found this
place that we spend you know every a
week a year at or yeah Kippy was saying
that before you got here we were curious
uh What uh if you did move out of the
city is there any place that we thought
about your eye we thought about this I
mean probably my wife's from Santa
Barbara so maybe like Los Angeles
because I still need to do stand-up
full-time competitively yeah yeah also
like in the city doing spots you know
you can't move to like [__] Toledo or
something exactly where's the last place
you were where's the last place you you
and the misses visited
where did we go because if you haven't
seen Schultz's Instagram the schultzers
do vacations well we had a bougie one we
went through all right that Arizona one
I'm on Gary yeah it's uh you're not
tipping out there everything they
probably don't like it's all crypto
probably you gotta give them a Bitcoin
or some [__] these new age Rich guys you
want to know class you gotta leave a
baby on the dresser in class dude this
place uh there's no money
so there's no bill there's no everything
there's no anything at all I think the
food is all included and then drinks you
can pay extra for but they never ask for
a bill so you don't tip the tip is
included 4200 tonight
yeah yeah but it's really it's like
you're paying [__] what are you doing
over there yeah I knew that price
because my wife just looked it up so we
could go and I was like I'm not schultzy
[__] it's wild let's go to Burning
Man or something yeah yeah yeah yeah
burn it up yeah yeah yeah you couldn't
afford to drive through the parking lot
it is a lot but we went we went there on
Thanksgiving weekend right or
Thanksgiving week and um I didn't even
look it up like an [__] like I just
saw it my wife showing me pictures like
oh it looks beautiful I didn't realize
it's on a [__] Native American
reservation everybody there is Native
American so I'm there Thanksgiving
right and all these poor names you guys
got any plans for the holidays
literally I got the saddest Happy
Thanksgiving ever from a native person
that was driving us to the airport yeah
right but no that place was I want to
spit in your food that hit me but no
bill ever they just ask you your room
number and then they put it on and the
tip is applied because yeah because this
this rich people don't ever want to they
don't want to do this why are you giving
me papers yes
Chelsea gives him a fake room number
yeah
I'm on the ninth floor
we don't have bees and seeds over here
it's right next to a you'll figure it
out more my ties please I just did
something in uh in Puerto Rico it was
the same thing it was a you know uh it
was a high-end luxury hotel where'd you
stay uh uh the Vanderbilt yeah uh uh and
it was the same thing you have to sign
which is fine but my whole thing is like
just running no sign I know which but
like the thing I was getting mad about
I'd go up to the bar at the pool and get
a Corona they print me two receipts I
gotta sign my room the name I go just
run it I'll figure it out later put it
into the room just go put it on this guy
came back upside down and brunch away
yeah I got jammed up at a [__] uh at
a at a what was what was that like a
chef's tasting thing they got jam it was
really way more and it's so lost on me
I'm a dirt bag I have a horrible I like
chicken tenders That's my kind of thing
I always say let's do it yeah so I got
the wine pairing I got [__] jammed up
and I hated the food well sticker shot
through the wine pairing you're in it a
little sticker shock first uh
what was it 1200 I think for two of us
and none neither one of us liked it yeah
it was a lot it was at least I'm that's
law I'd rather it's lost on me yeah yeah
give me a [__] I'm a shot and a beer
guy and uh so you're in Puerto Rico it's
not like they have like a rich wine
culture yeah no yeah exactly it wasn't
like we were in like France we need some
rum but then my wife got the mocktail
package yeah
wait a minute she paid but did she not
drink she doesn't drink okay so but they
had like a mocktail pairing by the way
and that was a hundred dollars that what
a racket that is
pineapple juice wow 100 bucks on it I
said shake a Snapple [__] we're out
of here wow that's next level oh wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's German
right German you're right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I'm kidding yeah I was having a uh a
dinner with a guy uh German dude the
other day and um they're unique people
well I I actually really enjoyed Germans
because you can oh I love it very direct
and honest oh they don't there's no
beating around the bush you find out
where you just dude this is how yeah
this is how ruthless my wife calls me a
successful podcaster and not comedian
I'm like you [__] [__] crazy she's
like yeah we were a podcaster I'm like
I'll [__] fight you right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I gotta I gotta ask
from the Every Man's perspective who who
was this guy I can't even tell who the
hell you're hanging out with these days
oh the German guy yeah you're hanging
out with like race car drivers and
financiers
Swiss bank accounts yeah he's a guy who
uh he works for uh yeah a company that
we might you know do some business with
right and that's real vague rich guy
[__] all right and no but he's I'm
saving it I want it in Arby's he had a
funny thing because I was you know he
brought up the school shootings in
America and I was like yo what do you
guys think about that like from Germany
like the school's the shooting thing and
he had an interesting uh idea on it that
I'm curious about your wife's
perspective and he goes he goes uh yeah
I mean it is so weird for us this is so
strange like why do you guys do this uh
but then again you know we have uh the
Autobahn I go what do you mean and the
Audubon is there like highway system and
you can drive as fast as you want and
every year their senseless deaths from
people driving too fast on the Audubon
and every year the government tries to
go well maybe we should just make some
restrictions so not everybody can drive
so fast on the Audubon and then Germans
go it is my right to drive to drive my
Mercedes as fast as I want you will not
take it away from it like they have the
exact same gun rights thing I can't take
my speed exactly I can't even kill Jews
anymore you're gonna take away my speed
you will take my driving gloves from my
cold dead hands
so I thought it was interesting that
like I never thought about it that way
but every guaranteed every culture every
country has the thing that they identify
with that makes no sense and causes
senseless deaths but they refuse to
relinquish it because they think it's an
attack on their identity that makes
sense of course yeah yeah I'm trying to
figure what the other ones are I never
thought of that like Italians with the
spaghetti
it's enough already
[Laughter]
um okay uh hold on speaking of a travel
uh this was a this is a hot button
debate on the Pod you're on a plane uh
you put the seat back on the plane
immediately immediately
the second I sit down the seat is back
okay they don't make you put it up on
takeoff
in first sometimes
that's the other that's another thing
that happened like I'm I'm flying first
yeah we don't go back we can't go it's
hard to go back for business personally
back uh but yeah it's uh yeah I just go
back immediately you say anything no
concern the only time I didn't do it is
when 50 Cent was sitting behind me and I
had so much respect what plane is this
I thought Tony Ayo was gonna come clip
me real quick Tony was in coach I love
you Tony
no but this guy fifty was behind me and
I have so much respect for 50. shout out
dude I didn't drop the seat back at all
did he go back do you know divorce
that's 50 Cent Billy's the big guy he
needs his room
but yeah I didn't go back at all that's
how much respect I ever fit bro do you
know him at all no no I mean we we
engaged there yeah we said hello and
everything and he gave me a look as if
maybe he knew me but like you know 50 is
the man like white boy crazy has [__]
straddled being famous making things in
Hollywood and saying whatever the [__]
he wants sure on social media and just
blatantly talk about shooting people at
the same time yeah like any any joke he
can make nobody's a single thing about
it like it's almost as if he has dirt on
every single important person in the
music business in Hollywood and politics
because there's nothing he can't say and
he has to apologize for nothing so it's
like he's the dream I'm like this guy
figured it out yeah shout out to fifth
huh yeah 50 is a legend you're taking
the shoes off on a plane
if it's like if if I'm wearing the New
Balance 550s they pinch my bunion and
I'll take them shits off immediately how
old are you 80. um
is the 550 the it's the shoe that got
really popular it'd be like kind of
replace like uh like almost like a Nike
Dunk
okay maybe Tupac right yeah yeah I got
you and um and yeah but I'll take those
if it's uncomfortable I'm taking the
shoe off absolutely if it's like a
running sneaker that I wore for the
airplane no I'm gonna you know leave it
on but I I have no qualms about taking a
shoe off and walking to the bathroom and
saying
son's shoes with socks stepping in the
the piss droplet sometimes with kids
dude yeah do you ever masturbate on a
plane I've tried
damn stewardess I want to give me my leg
room yeah yeah no I time it with the
stewardess making an announcement
keep going you're just in the bathroom
this is an affront to God man
thanks to Jim Carrey trying to pull one
no I don't know it's a hard thing to
like
a lot of people do it I've never it's
never really crossed my mind like why I
don't know yeah I mean I'm on so much
Propecia that like are you yeah I don't
have to shut up it's working better for
you though when did you how are you how
are you doing it took his first pillow
you just [__] crushing it up and then
just sweeping it into a Dustbin
funny
you're gonna destroy a sponsor of mine
have you been taking this bucket for a
bishop ready this guy ain't a client
what's going on yeah man I'm trying
you're trying to fight genetics don't
work so but you came on late oh wait I
should have if it was one of those
things I wish I would have started way
before yeah I started 23 bro oh no I
started 30
full you gotta get in what like the
second you notice anything you should
have started in eighth grade
were you one of those High School guys
[Laughter]
where that kid that went gray you're
like what the [__] was that all I was
insane yeah that was rough yeah we had a
kid go bald and he was a scene he was a
oh yeah it was a junior he was starting
to go back that's like dying or
something that ain't that's not normal I
think he was the the coach of the team
he would be in the layup lines with us
and the other team would be like I see a
player coach what's going on here it
must be a fifth year senior
um okay shower at night shower in the
morning
do you shower every night shower after
exercise and and if my if before sex if
my wife forces me to okay sounds like a
real romance
I mean you try to have kids today it
removes romances sure entirely I don't
know if you guys have tried at all for
that you guys not intentionally no no
wait are you guys pregnant no no did
that come off weird uh no we've never
tried I've had sex is what I'm trying to
say I don't think you have I'll be
honest it was a wild answer huh
breaking news right here wait you mean
when you put it you put the wee-wee in
the woohoo yeah are you guys going I'm
not a virgin yeah yeah uh are we going
out what do you mean yeah I have sex
with my wife no are you guys trying to
have a child no not at the moment no no
okay let me ask you how old do you mind
me asking how old your wife is uh we're
both 36 36 so you guys yeah it's got it
yeah why don't you come over we'll talk
about it I mean I'm telling you this is
no of course I know go after it I know I
because it's not when you start
it's a while after sure of course that's
what we're learning I know go after it
yeah okay I mean your wife doesn't I'm
coming up over here right am I the only
guy I said no she's on the mocktails 80
bucks a cliff yeah
all right so it's not it's not a
regimented thing your shots with my wife
oh no uh that is more regimen no I the
showers no I think if I work out if I
sweat if I don't if I'm not sweating I
don't really feel it you shower this
morning before you before you came in
yeah yeah yeah I worked out I did
Pilates if that isn't some [__] damn
yeah he did Pilates what'd you have for
breakfast this morning I had uh
oh a meal thing that that I'm doing so
like I'm getting these like meals gotcha
okay yeah you got a chef no that's what
you're telling me no no no so shout out
to the muscle dock uh Jordan shouse he's
he's the [__] man and uh nobody
bleeped out yeah believe it
but no I'm like
I had to get a cortisone shot my body's
starting to fall apart like everything
is just like oh you're gonna be doing
you're gonna be doing testosterone the
second my wife gets pregnant I'm On
Everything peptides
[Applause]
hghash is already on it really yeah I
don't think he cares about what I'm
saying this yeah yeah he's juicing he's
on the peptide he just started I like it
yeah yeah yeah if he wasn't angry enough
already that guy's got an edge to him
I would absolutely do it 100 this
Pilates you did it
uh why are you why don't you do the
[__] ozempic [__] if you're trying to
lose weight losem pick yeah this is what
all this this is the shots people you
just take a shot and then you [__]
lose the weight that's what everybody in
Hollywood you what this no thing yeah
heroin yeah all right but without the
sleepiness like you just have a great
day and you get your [__] done and the
CBD of heroin literally yeah no it's
just it's it was like a diabetes that
like regulates your blood sugar insulin
just makes you not hungry it's like so
this one every that's what you [__]
realize dude like uh all right you know
when you first started like getting some
[__] off and then you realize oh wow
like it's easier to get a restaurant
reservation or maybe these people want
to give us clothing it's still not easy
for me I don't know who you think coming
soon it's coming I got the knife from
Applebee's last week you can get a
hoagie at the Wawa there we go they know
me at the Wawa yeah so like uh you
realize like all these like um athletes
and everything not even athletes like
these Hollywood stars and everything
like that it's like they're not really
just kind of working out like us oh no
they're on
they got the trainers they got the food
and all this kind of [__] so
um yeah I don't know I'm down to do all
of that yeah I think yeah you're doing
the Pilates at the house no I go to this
studio real Pilates okay yeah but it's
uh it was a private session are you with
other people private session I had to
kind of rehab this [__] shoulder yeah
you're a real rich guy yeah I just don't
have confidence in my ability to do it
like I need someone who constantly can
like sure yeah yeah okay
um you're getting dressed in the morning
do you put socks on or pants first
do you go socks then pants or pants then
socks
either or
no it can't be tied down yeah yeah
okay fair enough fourth yeah I'm a pants
before socks kind of guy that makes
sense yeah when you're getting in the
shower yeah now see this is a little
tricky because I'm sure you have a glass
door right
back when you had just a regular curtain
so you're in a hotel room yeah like a
like a shittier hotel room yep not not
one of the five thousand dollar a night
won't you stay out would you get in
towards the front of the shower or the
back of the shower what do you think's
oh the back of the shower and then enter
the water of course you're not just
jumping right in the [__] right in
the splash it jumps right into the Splat
he does and he even sneaks around the
door you have the square footage to
block the water and I'm not trying to
make it like it's like putting a wall up
exactly just told me about the ozone
picks well and I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to bully you I am you are what
I'm saying is you can push the water in
a direction away from you it's hitting
the tile if we walk in it's just a
little guys like that's spraying it up
just hold my titty up yeah I can't hit
all right okay all right uh do you know
any of the lyrics from the Eight Mile
battle raps
um you went to Cranbrook that's a
private school yeah okay yeah that's not
classy yeah no I know that I might know
that that whole thing probably yeah
we were that was like oh great yeah also
I like how Eminem did it kind of like
Howard Stern where it's just like one
movie knock it out of the park
shout out to private parts private parts
was I mean does it hold up because I
thought it was unbelievable I don't know
not that long ago top shelf movie yeah I
mean what he did is truly unbelievable I
want it done no I'm just saying oh his
career right of course shout out to him
I mean yeah imagine one of the A's of
the goat he's the greatest literally
what about uh what what goes on first
the deodorant or the shirt
uh deodorant yeah yeah right out the
shower suckers deodorant I go sure thank
you
that's smart it gets on your clothes use
the white deodorant I use yeah I use uh
secret what are you using or Dove I use
the white right if you use the white you
got to put God first 100 yeah um I want
you jamming up yeah I think Old Spice or
something my wife really yeah I figured
it was some real rich guy [__]
honestly I don't really buy many things
guys to be honest with you like I don't
know that jacket looks pretty nice
what's the soap it looks like a Crown
Royal bag
this [__] guy coming in here in a
velvet jacket with gold trim and I'm not
supposed to say anything I got a
hackered for some Hennessy I'll tell you
that like some Incredible Hulks in here
so Crown and Coke on a rock let's go
[Laughter]
it's mostly experiences that's what I'm
trying to go into the [__] crazy
hotel or doing Italy sure and yeah trips
and then trying to do those trips with
with the boys and their wives like that
is that's the peak if you could get that
down like do like a summer thing and
like a winter thing and you just you
know just live life baby yeah man that
is that is just with us grateful and
live life trust me I don't want to brag
but we got Connecticut coming up
shout out to you see you soon baby where
you guys going in Connecticut uh the
venue yeah it's New Haven it's a like a
rock Clubby performance space yeah yeah
cool graduating a little bit out of the
clubs doing some things
I thought we were down we were down
there in Tejas as we were saying and we
had it we had it oh yeah what'd you
think about the mothership I I mean
unbelievable huh yeah it's like a guy
who knows a lot about comedy made a
really good comedy club it's the corners
are all rounded on that thing it's
[__] place in a good way I mean yeah
place is sharp it's run sharp Comics are
all sharp everybody is nice as [__]
unbelievable now were you guys nervous
going on I was [__] crazy nervous
dude just because you're like what the
[__] it's yeah it's Rogan's Club I I had
only met him tell him what happened I
had only met him a second before right
like he came into the Green Room hey how
you doing Mr Rogan you know what I mean
and then I ran off to the corner and uh
so then I'm going up they're bringing me
up on stage and they do like to pass the
mic type thing yeah and uh I'm about to
go up and it's your boy Derek white that
was my Derek's great uh and hysterical
man yeah hysterical killer great guy
yeah we're gonna have him on here next
time he's in New York and uh he's uh
good dude so I I never met him but I
knew him through like you know you guys
working together and I was like hey
what's up man I'm Kevin you know I'm
actually like yeah what's up cool cool
cool so then he's on stage and they're
like all right he's lit and I went in
and I'm you know you did that you've
done you've been there right the small
room so I'm like against the wall in the
small room about to get called up yeah
and he's like this night Derek's like
this next guy you know uh my brother in
comedy and I'm like well that ain't me
dude I'm like this ain't this ain't
[__] good I didn't realize that I was
like oh that's so sweet what a good guy
he thought he was just like being up and
up with you yeah like being like Oh I
love this Comedy Central
so I'll write them I know I'm like I'm
dead in the water whoever it is this
ain't good yeah and he's like ladies and
gentlemen Joe Rogan and it was like
throwing a [__] hand grenade
one guy stabbed himself nuts uh because
everybody bought those tickets to see
how they got this
off the best they never thought Rogan's
gonna come on we gotta take us to the
small room he pops in he's [__] you
know I mean he's killing and then
they're like all right we don't you know
we're not sure how long he's doing like
we don't know if he's gonna bring it we
don't know anything and they were like
we'll bring you up over the god mic or
someone will run up on stage he doesn't
know you certain deaths yeah so I'm like
oh man I'm [__] dead to rights I
gotta [__] follow him I gotta it's
like following Jesus in heaven is what
you gotta do
that's a tough follow and a tough man he
walked back to them he walked back to
the back of the room waddle him back
like an open mic oh dude I came back I
turned my head wouldn't look at him
don't come to me for sympathy
I was like hey man you want to go next
I'll give you 100 bucks
so then he goes up and then he [__]
so I'm like all right and then he's like
all right you guys have been great and
I'm like all right let's see [__] how
this is just I'm gonna be executed if he
gets off that stage and every because
like 20 people got up to you know to to
on anybody is that creates a [__] that's
that big in that place it's a buzz for
you know so he goes but if there's
silence on the stage and all of you here
next up on the stage it's like it's like
being lost at Kmart as a kid
we have a five-year-old in aisle eight
we got a guy that's gonna try to do
comedy next that's what's he says he's
on Propecia we don't believe him
so then shout out to him [__] uh Mr
Rogan oh Rogan did it goes guys you've
been great you know yada yada yada next
I come to Stage from the are you garbage
podcast Kevin Ryan so now I [__] myself
flip it
if you don't think I saved that that
[__] Instagram it doesn't even go up
just walks up
ain't gonna get better than this guys
and it did not
[Laughter]
I'm not even [__] around about 25
people got up and there's that place is
just above the holy [__] that guy yeah
they get up to go to the bathroom
because he did you know a longer set so
whatever I think people were like this
is not much I just got to see one of the
rest of the famous people in human
history was in a room with 50 people and
then just left yeah exactly it was gonna
be an energy show yeah yeah yeah so then
like I get out there dude
[Applause]
how [__] awesome is that to buy
myself you know 15 20 seconds whatever
um but then it's like all right you
gotta [__] settle and just I just
started [__] clipping away at it then
probably 90 seconds yeah two man 90
seconds
I'm connected and then by the end of the
set I was [__] crushing great happy
with it and he brought me up and I
started murdering
[Music]
did you guys ever talk before about who
should go first no they it was an order
it was like yeah they were like hey
you're next I caught my medicine on
Sunday but I had a little bit of a
buffer because it was it was yeah it's a
that was a different kind of medicine
Derek was hosting on Sunday yeah and I
just happened to got the lucky to draw
uh Rogan went up and then and then I had
to go after him how was it I was
treading water for a little bit I'll be
honest with you but that was awesome God
damn [__] Joe Rogan what do you want
from that was that like we all went up
at the end of like the four hour open
mic so it was like the mistakes were
there was like you know it wasn't a full
it wasn't like a [__] the stakes were
a little different yeah but
and the most generous and I mean he
doesn't want me sharing how he's going
to be paying the comics there but like
no Comedy Club has ever paid comics in
this way it's like astronaut it really
is the mothership I mean it really is
it's such a [__] beautiful and we
were telling him man we still like shout
out to Texas uh we were at uh we were
hanging out at mitzi's as well you know
it's the bar downstairs and they closed
it off for staff and and Comics so it's
like Savage chill too
A lot of them are funny and [__] too man
yeah a couple of killers so we were
there hanging out in the bar and it was
just sitting there and I was like it's
one of those things where I'm like oh
man I haven't I'm like you could feel
the [__] energy that's like not
really in New York as much as it used to
be after the pandemic I'm like oh man
this is what it was like there's just
like a Vibe of everybody like we're
[__] hanging we're doing it it's such
a new fun energy yeah that I was like
damn that's what I was telling him like
Dan you there's something [__]
tangible in the air I mean think about
like why would if you're comic that's
been you know grinding in New York or La
for years and you're like a professional
you got a great set you're hilarious but
it just hasn't caught on for whatever
reason why would you not go there I
would I would be there after we started
Zillow and properties the next morning
Tony was giving us the Hard Sell he's
like you got kids we're like no he's
like shout out to Mr hinchcliff yeah
yeah the whole [__] Squad down there
is fantastic yeah no they're they're
just killing it man they're just [__]
killing it was an honor to uh honor to
be there yeah go check it out yeah
that's the hardest thing it really is a
[__] experience man it's an
experience yeah it's just great to see I
don't I mean like look I'm the biggest
fan of Joe obviously but it's really
cool to see somebody be put in that
position because oftentimes people get
put in positions of of power and then
they just repeat the same things sure
sure that the other people empowered it
sure so you see it with music all the
time it's like these artists go all
these these music deals are horrible and
then they get offered a label and it's
the same [__] music
exactly yeah so it's like Kanye was
bitching and whining about his deal and
then had a bunch of other musicians
under the same [__] sure anyway so
like he goes and does a club and then
does the exact opposite thing oh it's
like well that's what he said when we
were talking I was like hey man you've
made it I was like comedy is number one
here like that's the only thing because
they don't have a kitchen they don't
have a kitchen no but I'm seeing it in
the club I'm like you've made comedy
yeah they're not selling chicken fingers
there's no [__] whatever whatever I
go comedy's number one I was like
comedy's put first or is number one he
goes yeah it's the only thing it's the
only that's the only thing that matters
in this building is comedy and I was
like [__] yeah no that's great like no
one's doing that yeah did you guys get
to go up in the big room too we did yeah
what'd you think about the big room it's
[__] sick man you get to be performed
like you get to you have to refill the
room yeah I think that's important I
think that's something that New York
doesn't really have anymore especially
now that like Caroline's clothes I guess
with Gotham you could kind of it's a
bigger performative room right yeah it's
like once you start doing these theaters
it's like you can't lean up on a brick
wall sure and that's how we all grow up
yeah yeah back against the wall yeah
it's just chilling I mean and then you
got 3 000 people in front of you in the
theater it's like okay this needs to be
a different type of [__] you gotta step
forward you gotta [__] shoulders up
yeah yeah I mean when we did The
Gramercy that was a big thing of like oh
[__] you got to fill this stage yeah
step in the Footlights baby yeah let's
go yeah congrats on that man thank you
go great three sold out they were
[__] fantastic shout out to the bozos
in the homes yes Army of garbage came
correct it was surreal surreal moment
beautiful yeah
um but uh you keep the customer receipt
show
no I don't never do you take it with you
or do you leave it there I don't I
signed the customers like whatever's on
top I signed uh and you leave the blank
one there yeah I got jammed up one time
guy put a 500 tip on a set of chicken
sure I get jammed up over and over again
I do not look at my credit card this is
awful I don't look at my credit card
statement everybody oh you got a guy
that does that you got to have a
businessman but did they really look at
it like how do they know I didn't buy
that sure what are they gonna call me
they're gonna see three charges at New
Balance think about it usually you only
get two shoes there's no way that they
would know so he's not looking everybody
that works with me has my credit card
everybody that works me as passwords to
everything that I have like it's yeah I
don't really have that's okay I don't
know if I could ever give up that level
of
I mean bird has the same thing Bird's
like somebody he rolls with his
assistant Peter he was like hey do you
have my credit card and my cash you're
just wandering around yeah that's wild I
mean I I got great guys and I trust sure
but also I think it's a little bit more
like how do I create more room for me to
focus on things that I really want to
focus of course yeah no totally true
totally true like stand up man it's fun
to get
yeah it's just fun to be back in it like
because I took a little time off after
the special yeah and like
in the in writing a new new material was
hard man yeah it's tough It's the
hardest thing to do because yeah because
you don't want to you don't want to make
that mistake that I think a lot of us
make which is like you just do different
versions of the jokes you already did
sure it's like the same mechanism but
you're like I'm at the hospital now it's
a pretty good idea
I could squeeze one more hour out of
this a fat guy on a boat instead of a
plane what do you think
but that is that is what we what we've
got to do and it's like you're not
reacting to like the change in life and
I always wanted the the comedy to be
like the most pure and authentic as it
could be like you know I look up the
guys like Patrice who was like authentic
to almost a fault yeah of course yeah
but it's like it was just so beautiful
so I went through a lot of life change
but I had that set for
three years because of covet so all
these things change in my life but the
material didn't really yeah you're still
doing the the previous thing so so like
starting from scratch was like really
[__] tough but I didn't want to just
repeat the kind of same things I was
doing and now kind of coming through and
like it's starting to mold and work and
just being like addicted to it again
sure it'll go through those swings of
like oh it's working oh this is great
this is so much fun and then you go
through two weeks of it sucking you're
like oh I'm [__] absolutely but at
least at least the addiction is there
before if the addiction isn't there
you're like when it's going bad you're
like what the [__] is going on like I
feel horrible whatever but now it's just
like this this game I want to solve so
yeah I saw you a few months ago a little
while back and I was like how's the
how's it going with the new stuff and
you're like man I got 15 and you were so
yeah yeah
it's like
[Laughter]
it's so weird how this [__] works it's
like you you'll get 30 and that 30
becomes 10. yeah and then you get 40 and
that 40 becomes 20. it's just you
Whittle away all the [__] no I know
but I don't know I'm excited about it I
kind of want to go hit clubs again to be
honest with you like on the road yeah
because it's like what made what made
the last hour and the hours before that
great the pressure cooker of a club yeah
I think it's the grind I think it's
doing five shows a weekend if you're in
a theater and you're doing two shows
you're doing a show Friday show Saturday
you keep it moving it's like okay that
is a fraction of the amount of shows and
it's like I think I need to I think I
just need it but it's also a different
like we were talking about it's a
different you it's a different at the
theater you're performative so your
writing process on stage is going to be
a little different oh yeah it's much
harder to write in on stage in a theater
oh yeah like because you're yeah you're
you're it's more outward rather than
like you're not in the mix you're not
like Tango with the audience also the
bombs are just loud
like hearing 5 000 people not laugh not
laugh
back at the theater just here what yeah
what's this guy's deal so it needs to be
ready you know what I mean like you
can't be up there just [__] winging
it in front of 5 000. I know so yeah I
like that 5000c theater you got a
notebook yeah yeah let me try this one
try this one I got a babysitter you
bastard yeah how dare you try some [__]
it's got to be ready bro if you're in
the theaters it's got to be ready of
course you know but yeah yeah I'm
excited about it that's sick yeah we
gotta go do some shows guys let's do it
you should we should go do some shows I
love that yeah we're running a little
we're running out of time here so let's
get this we have some patreon questions
that we gotta get to here I'll choose
yeah uh this one's from Polly Wallace
this is an OG one but being a man of
your stature and also of your wife a bit
of a foodie do you have any collection
of condiment packets from any
restaurants in your refrigerator at this
time this is from Polly walnuts oh [__]
that's a good one any [__] soy sauce
honestly we must I'm I'm sure we do but
there are restaurants that I would like
love to get some packaged sauce from
well like yeah what's in here that Raul
steak sauce right there that Raul that's
a place
I want that package
absolutely great question but uh yeah if
I could get the vodka sauce from
Carbones that we brushing my teeth talk
about the Chick-fil-A specials we should
do a nice little carbon dinner boys yeah
you got I can't make that happen we'll
do this I can't even get a reservation
at Gallagher's Steakhouse they got us
waiting in the foyer like [__] tell
me I gotta take my baseball hat off I'm
there with the with the coach at girl oh
my goddamn dick in my hand how long
you've been working here this guy we got
people are handing you jackets
now we should have a nice little dinner
out that'd be fun yeah dude let's go
that's a youth thing let's do it we make
it happen I promise we got to do some
shows together and we gotta do a nice
little dinner out actually I mean that's
one of my favorite parts of being on the
road is uh just the dinner after a show
we don't that we run in a problem
because you do we do weekdays so we go
in Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and if
you're in Addison if you're at the
Addison Improv on a Wednesday you get
done at 10 30 after the meet and greet
and everything yeah all right not an
open you're at a [__] you're lucky to
get a Hooters or something yeah we're at
a Cheesecake Factory I'm walking through
the menu like a [__] Minefield dude
that is a fantastic restaurant
Cheesecake Factory the consistency it's
flawless I just recently got introduced
to it it's like two three years ago it's
been magnificent it's the best and
another way right now it's
people who think they're better than
[__] cheesecake big seats big tables
big personalities
huge menu and tons of options the
interior of the place is great
Immaculate it's like done by like I'll
[__] corporate you know Tim Jones big
on the corporate Steakhouse like yeah
it's perfectly executed yes the menus
made in a board room yeah there's 10
people thought about this not one
[__] guy and you can go in Salt Lake
or Long Island like that tastes exactly
give me the chicken mouth give it up
wrap it up let's give it up uh all right
let's see let's do uh two more here this
one's from Isaac is it garbage to keep
the sticker on a fitted cap as a fashion
statement
for sure
back in the day we did it I thought that
was more Hood than garbage uh yeah but I
think it's uh if you're Flex it depends
what sticker did you keep the shiny one
yeah
if you leave the [__] one with the
size
that's a [__] come on what are we
doing everyone needs to know it's seven
and a quarter seven and a half
will you wear your sneakers out of a
sneaker store when you buy sneaks and
wear them out
back in the day yeah yeah because I I
think I was probably just so excited to
have the sneakers that I was like yeah
I'm wearing these [__] yeah
but now no no no you can't do that
um uh let's see uh this one's from JJ
have you or anyone in your family ever
used a money clip
yeah I used to think the money clip is
the coolest thing because there was that
Nicholas Cage John Travolta movie face
off where he had a gold Glock or a gold
gun Desert Eagle or something like that
and a gold money clip and I thought that
that money clip was the coolest [__]
thing in the world so I tried to do
money clip that was a good movie
Nicholas Cage underrated one of my
favorites not a bad rap but he's [__]
fantastic it's like one of these these
people like gets it's like it becomes
cool to hate and it's just like if you
actually look at how he is as an actor
he's one of the best yeah he's having a
25-year career Leaving Las Vegas
National Treasure one of the most fun
movies
wow Conair was incredible come on guys
got range you got a rainy day around the
holidays throw on the family man with
Nicholas Cage I don't think I've ever
seen her home run it's a reverse of It's
a Wonderful Life okay home runs okay
home run okay love Nick Cage shout out
to Nick Cage we gotta wrap it up gang
okay buddy we love you so much we love
you guys so proud of what you guys have
done it's been incredible we can't thank
you enough my friend dude don't thank me
man you guys did this [__] all of you
guys did this [__] and it's great that
you guys have so much support and yeah I
mean just awesome seeing what you guys
built so let's get a nice little dinner
on the books and then honestly mean that
like let's let's uh oh we're gonna have
some [__] but let's do some shows I
think that'd be fun if you're doing
we'll go we'll [__] open up for you
let's do it oh yeah that's what I was
saying
Hey listen
hey let's drop it in
get all your fans there I'll close huh
no she's hosting
Chelsea do 10 and don't go over your
time either I got the big man back here
make sure you do the birthdays don't
forget the comment cards all right
buddy what else you want the folks out
there no you got anything hey man just
you know YouTube check all this stuff
out man check out everything thank you
guys so much I appreciate it Kippy shout
out Schultz thank you so much man we're
all over the road tickets are going
quick get those now we're announcing the
second leg soon I'm dropping in I'm
coming
and I'm coming and I'm opening up I'm
not following schultzier
he's going before Toby
all right boys buddy I love you Toby I
love you Schultz we love you I love you
love you guys we'll see you next week